as I was I say almost every day like
when I finally when I finally go back
home back these yeah people are gonna
think I'm lying making up stories but
some of the things that have me watch TV
see that's why they call me DC my kids
actually live in Virginia but yes crazy
never ceases to make like I've been in
seven years and it's still [ __ ] that can
happen all right
daily bases that make up yeah yeah yeah
yeah I got 300
yeah actually today's I'm street
cleaning day yeah every two weeks and
then so what are you doing money I sell
pallets you saw pallets yeah
you're resourceful that's not different
yeah and see because it is a endless
supply of them you know it just you just
have to think of where to go when they
go there and after a while certain
people will remember certain people like
you some people don't like you you just
have to find a way around things to get
the palace capela ours is one the main
ones here on a series right up the
street from where they
Carrie palette over dumb basket a
persona back Sakura or pal exactly
something's initiate it does yeah he be
surprised
[Music]
it's cardiovascular and I take like a
breaker at some time off and I try to do
it again I get surprised how when did I
get tired
I mean breaks I have to take I do this
year
well yeah you're right so are you well
I smoke weed everyday smoke we everyday
for most of my life cocaine
let me watch Chris Annette and already
like it and sometimes PCP
what's the difference there's too much
dependency on now okay take your cracker
yeah and powder there's a know the
difference between crack and powder is
just the UH they heard you see of the
rush which is the same rush but it's
already a syllabus with practice faster
much more much much more potent and
these much much more faster okay which
is more urgency so they knew okay
and then it's like over so then it
creates another urgency to keep it going
yeah
[Music]
Jackie smoked a lot when I was younger
too but in DC we call it Love Boat angel
dust face
over here funny cuz like is this is
where they were getting it well la it's
like la a DC pipeline so
I stopped a long time family where was
that in freighter
it kills your motor skills that would
sound really see one hand I remember was
nothing it's like it's like Tylenol yeah
it's false at you you're tired you don't
know it it is aam be leave your cocaine
like okay you go stay in the 30 minutes
or hour without any and your body
catches up you just shut it down
it's a crystal meth doesn't really get
to be like knocked out it was the most
popular industry here
crack but Kristen matches judging up
rapidly because some people consider it
like a graduation because then I'd spend
as much money
but it's it's a false Jesus I I um I
compared the Town Hall the Town Hall
doesn't really kill pain or stopped me
and tricks your brain and the same thing
some people get this work just imagine
same way tricks your brain thinking
you're getting closer
not really an opening up at all like
that well rarely do I grew up in Chicago
that's Rock remover I was in a different
hitter
probably so were you born Cook County
Hospital
you might even like neighborhood Evans
Danny Skokie
yeah yeah I grew up in Chicago I was 10
years old my mom
she got me 11 months as she had my
sister we have different dads she was in
college but she had like she had
tendencies to run the streets and then
dude do-while stuff I have my ladies
tickets it borrows and racetracks four
five three four five
[Music]
pool balls retracts like that always
about at that time at the time yeah yeah
mid 20 from um she got in trouble we had
to go to foster care
me my sister my little brother you save
I got in trouble she I put in prison man
um she still won't let me know
completely what to make diets like that
yeah but
she ended up being able to get us back
she got out she got back she was a born
again Christian out there but I still
remember her you know who she is
learning that Christian stuff anyway she
got a job transferred when I was 10
years old to Washington DC she thought
it was better enemy because she's in the
building the project building out there
dad was a gangster disciple
controllability and they started no they
recruit like like boys and surveys see
certain he saw certain things I mean I
think one of these and I never they were
teaching me [ __ ] good she she saw it she
liked it
I said get away
ironically he wouldn't dc-dc was no
better that's when I was really really
really cracked out and Mary bear ISM and
I was in Chicago remove the DC to get
away from that yeah
DC's no better we didn't know it was
there no sputter poverty that's what was
gained poverty progress especially then
Marion Barry remember when the same year
1991
she wanted us to go back schools after
like maybe like two years she had
removed in Virginia Northern Virginia
suburbs the DC stuff you better life
better schools yeah that's where the
irony comes in that's right I got you
know all the trouble real Recaro I was
13
call my first
9:13 was first time I smoked weed for
some I drank recently and sex
with someone drove a car first my first
felony my first charge period for his
gun charge all I should have
administered second turn 30 and so I was
a convicted felon
actually before I ever had sex of course
first time in my life yeah
that what were you in prison for a lot
prison in jail either one mostly just
not going what they say
I haven't really done anything right
so heinous that she had to be locked
away in there it's mostly okay you're on
probation you know these rules quality
rules we'll give you one more chance
you're disrespecting the judge
probably 30 yes
tolya activity 8:30 or 2 months we'd
like to see yourself a fighter that my
kids with the story to tell help
somebody else not do this
that's where I will be
and inspiration if you want if we can
overcome this you know become anything
and I know I will yes this is the bottom
line
yeah this is the voice the artists way
of life
there is funny because we think in
America live like this and also in
America has no clue
and it's really just about anything is
noticing it seeing it doesn't really
help you to not be very pacified
we're north pay rent okay you girls
I mean the weather permits it they
bringing food whenever you close
anyone can get just don't like we all go
man it's all right I guess I'll feed you
your clothing see you can live here for
free
you know nowhere else like this anywhere
we can't live on this sidewalk
summertime hurry up and say get your ass
off the sidewalk